hey guys I'm just McDonald it is the
20th of January and you're watching
games what news whether you happen to be
an American on holiday or just a working
schmuck like the rest of us I've got
most of the gaming news you want to hear
about all wrapped up right here remember
how there was that whole reform thing
where they told people that no footage
was to be linked from the titanfall
alpha well that lasted all of five
seconds because footage has indeed been
linked from the titanfall alpha the
internet being what it is wasn't so
inclined to take no for an answer when
it came to wanting to see what were
being sought for them in the mech heavy
shooter it seems that respawn stern
statement that the limited technical
test was strictly not shareable was no
match for the participants desire for
upvotes and internet praise since alpha
gameplay has already hit vermeer
dailymotion and blip respawn are the
very least administering damage control
by reminding gamers that the footage
isn't representative of the final
product nonetheless to check out the
leaked footage and let me know whether
you think titanfall looks any good so
far in fairly disappointing new Star
Wars 1313 may well and truly be no more
since disney has abandoned the trademark
that's according to an update on the
United States Patent and Trademark
Office website to the third-person
action-adventure dropped into existence
at e3 2012 and with cancelled in april
2013 as a result of dizzy shutting down
LucasArts so is it goes the anticipated
title which was set to star Boba Fett as
its protagonist is looking to be pretty
done and dusted we particularly excited
for 13 13 or are you happy to just
transfer that excitement to star wars
battlefront let me know Nintendo might
be having tough times again after
suffering a 15-percent plunge in shares
after announcing their negative sales
projections the publisher have spent the
last several days going from whatever
the opposite of strength to strength is
first up they revised their sales
projections for the Wii U and the 3ds
decreasing their figures for expected we
use
almost seventy percent then they said
they expect to post a lot of what
amounts to 240 million us for the year
and to top it all off Satoru Iwata has
come out to say that he does not intend
to resign as nintendo's president do you
think Nintendo is doomed or can they
pull themselves back up again if you'd
like to hear my opinions on the matter
I've left some suggestions in this
week's episode of the gist so that's the
thing you could check out let me know
your comments either in the section down
below or on my Twitter where I'm at just
McDonald those are the good bad and poor
Nintendo stories I've got for you today
but be sure to join me again tomorrow
where I'll have a bunch more news I'm
just miguel and i'll see you again singh